following the bombing of Pan Am flight
103 over Scotland a deal was reached
between Gaddafi of Libya and the British
government in which the trial of the
accused bombers would happen in a
neutral country in return for the
extradition of the accused bombers the
Netherlands agreed to host the trial and
so portion of the Netherlands a former
NATO base called Camp Zeist became a
piece of Scottish land in the
Netherlands this Lane was part of
Scotland with Scottish police officers
Scottish judges and Scottish law thus
the court established on the site for
the proceedings was dubbed the Scottish
Court in the Netherlands following the
trial and a subsequent appeal the lane
was ceded back to the Netherlands but
for that short time Scotland was just a
tiny bit bigger across the channel in
the area that's always Scotland there
are two islands called westerly and Papa
westerly the airports of these two
islands can boast that between them runs
the shortest regularly scheduled
commercial flight in the world it takes
a mere minute cost 17 pounds and travels
1.7 miles roughly the same distance as
the runway of the airport of Edinburgh
the capital of Scotland there are a
number of places also called Edinburgh
around the world but the coolest is a
member of the seven seas located on the
British overseas territory island of
Tristan da Cunha number of the seven
seas is considered to be the most remote
inhabited place on earth the island is
1,200 miles from the closest other
inhabited place the island of Saint
Helena and 1500 miles from the nearest
continental and South Africa there's no
airport and no regular transport links
off the island the only way the 300
residents can reach the rest of the
world is by hitching a ride on a fishing
boat and those only come 8 or 9 times a
year at 64 square miles Tristan da Cunha
is the 1060 a--the largest island in the
world but the eighth largest island in
the world is Victoria Island Canada on
Victoria Island there's a lake which is
home to an island which has a lake on it
with one more Island this tiny 4 acre
island is so remote that it's
thought that no human has ever set foot
on it Victoria Island the island that
holds the lake that holds the island has
the lake with this island is slightly
bigger than Great Britain it has a
population of less than 2,000 also in
Canada but much farther south is
Vancouver about 22 miles south of
downtown Vancouver's point roberts
washington which is part of the united
states however you cannot get to the
rest the United States without crossing
into Canada this is because point
Robert's lies south of the 49th parallel
which constitutes much of the border
between the two countries
a few thousand miles to the east the
border isn't quite as nice and straight
in Detroit you can are intuitively have
to travel south to get to Canada
America's northern neighbor also
counter-intuitively the westernmost
point of Virginia is actually more
westerly than the westernmost point of
West Virginia and to finish off the
counterintuitive lease the eastern end
of the Panama Canal flows into the
Pacific Ocean the ocean to the west
while the western end of the Panama
Canal flows into the Atlantic Ocean the
ocean to the east and while we're so
close to South America I might as well
mention that there are no bridges over
the Amazon River the second longest
river in the world this is not because
the river is too wide or anything but
rather because pretty much nobody lives
around the Amazon there's actually only
one bridge over any of the major
tributaries to the Amazon as well for
the few roads there are that cross the
Amazon ferries connect the two sides and
to finish it off let's head over to
Afghanistan which has a time zone of UTC
plus 4 hours and 30 minutes they're one
of a few nations in the world that align
themselves to a half hour difference
compared to Universal Time Afghanistan
here's a brief 47 mile border with China
which has one timezone for the entire
country this means that if you step
across the Afghanistan China border you
travel three and a half hours into the
future and this is the greatest time
zone change you can make in one step on
earth
let's already - are you store Americans
a particular love shopping this reason
the door the cursor strove to break
inside check out